[Music]
this is from ivy patton any thoughts on
gap year travel all to ed for young
adults not in lieu of college
necessarily but as a way to better
understand yourself before the enormous
investment of a college education
furthering the truth that not all
classrooms have four walls and not all
people are cut out for desk learning so
perhaps the question is do you think
college is a must well let me back up
and comment on
the lead
which was related to gaap year i think
that
almost everyone would benefit from
having the option of a gap year in the
united states
and i would love one option for that gap
year to be national service of some type
that could be peace corps it could be
volunteering with a national non-profit
like teach for america
it could be military it could be
anything but
and that was actually suggested on this
podcast
so i've absorbed a lot from my guests
but i do think a gap year whether that
is traveling abroad whether that is
doing something in the united states but
stepping outside of the four walls of
the classroom to really gain
life experience that broadens your
thinking
of the world and the people in the world
is tremendously tremendously valuable
as to the question of
whether or not college is a must
it's hard to say that anything is a must
there are always exceptions right so i
can't say college is a must
but what i will say is that for
at this point in time for most people
if we're approaching it from a
professional perspective
the vast majority of people will benefit
from having a college degree
there are always these tales
of the bill gates the zuckerbergs
and so on who drop out of stanford or
harvard or wherever it might be
but there's some fine print on that that
is really important
those people very rarely drop out
they are not burning their ships they're
taking a leave of absence
many of these schools will allow you to
take a leave of absence and come back
and finish your degree at any point in
time that is not the same as dropping
out it is also not the same as not going
to college
if you attend stanford if you attend
harvard and you say i dropped out of
stanford i dropped out of harvard and
you succeed and people repeat that you
are still getting the benefit
of the blue chip branding associated
with stanford or harvard right so it's
important to recognize that
and i would be very skeptical of anyone
who has benefited a lot from a degree or
a diploma
if they tell you that you should not go
to college
i would carefully assess how that has
impacted their trajectory for instance
going to princeton help me it absolutely
helped me was it necessary
hard to say
but did it open doors did it allow me to
get replies to emails and so on where
otherwise i think it would have been
harder absolutely
so one could say from a professional
perspective i'm going to come back to
the topic of education and and cognition
more broadly speaking
but from the professional perspective
you know one could make the argument
that if you can get into an excellent
school
it is more valuable than getting into a
non-excellent school i happen to think
again for most people a college degree
is going to be of great benefit whether
or not
it is a top tier school
when it gets to
mbas
and things like that
professional degrees graduate degrees
if you are doing it for professional
advancement
let's take a look at an mba program i
think that the value of an mba is
dramatically lowered if you are not
going to one of the top 10 15 schools
in the country
who are well known for their mba
programs
that advice could differ if you are
coming out of a management consulting
job or
one of the big five accounting firms
within which
getting an mba
is encouraged for career advancement
promotion where they pay your way that
is a different situation
all right let's come back to the broader
question
do you think college is a must but now
let's look at it
from
the perspective of what i would consider
in the most literal sense not in the
typical sense a liberal arts education
so this this again differs a little bit
in it from technical
degrees but i never received a technical
degree so i can't really speak to that
i do think that going to a school
and
not going to say it's a must but going
to college
being forced to take
mandatory coursework
and then depending on your department
having required coursework and course
load
broadens your intellectual curiosity i
do think at least in my case
you end up taking things that you
expected not to like that you really
like you take things that you thought
you'd like that you really don't like
you take things that you thought you'd
be terrible at that you turn out to be
pretty good at
you take classes you think are going to
breeze that completely kick your ass and
i do think that broader education
with assignments how old-fashioned am i
are really valuable to someone in that
phase of life that being the age range
of an undergrad because you don't know
what you want
even though you might think you do you
don't know what you're best at
you don't know
where your life will be in two three
four five years
and
it is absurd to think that you have
comprehensive
self-awareness of your
strengths and weaknesses you simply
don't and you're not cognizant of where
you have the greatest potential either
in that case i do think there's a
benefit to
college so to speak now could that take
the form of something online yes could
it take the form of something
in another format absolutely
but
most people left to their own devices
without some
investment of time and money and without
the accountability of classmates and
having to be a certain place at a
certain time are just not going to study
as much
as people who are operating within those
constraints
and constraints aren't always things
that prevent you from doing what you
want to do sometimes constraints
are the things that you erect or that
you
deliberately engage with so that you can
focus
on doing the thing you want to do so i
think positive constraints are very
important so that's a long answer but
ivy pattern i hope that helps
you